ja willkommen zu aktuellen Sitzung der
digitalen ersatzsitzung für den 7 juni
2023 heute geht es um Immanuel Kants
Begriff der Tugend und zwar in seiner
Schrift mit der physische Anfangsgründe
der Tugendlehre das ist ein Teil seiner
sogenannten Metaphysik diejenigen die
sich für ganz Grundlegung zu Metaphysik
interessieren mache ich oben rechts ein
Link zur Playlist zu diesem Seminar noch
hinein Kant möchte hier jetzt keine
Grundlegung zu Metaphysik der sieht mehr
machen als eine metaphildeten ist eine
Ethik die aus reiner Vernunft reiner
praktischer Vernunft entwickelt wird
unabhängig von Erfahrung sie möchte
jetzt ganz konkret diese metaphysiken
aus arbeiten und wir haben jetzt hier
ein paar Leitfaden was versteht kann
unter einer Tugend
was versteht kein unter einem Laster wir
wollen ja immer wie Tugend und das
Laster positiv und negative Formen
betrachten und dann was versteht Kant
unter einer Tugend Leere und zum Schluss
wie verhält sich kannst du Begriff zu
demjenigen von aristotel ist wenn wir
intensiv diskutiert haben ja wir haben
jetzt hier ein paar Zitate ganzer Tugend
bedeutet eine moralische Stärke des
Willens also Willensstärke könnte man
sagen Tugend ist die moralische Stärke
des Willens eines Menschen in
Bevölkerung seiner Pflicht und Pflicht
haben wir gesehen ist moralische
Nötigung also die Stärke diese Pflicht
diese Pflicht gerecht zu werden diese
Pflicht nachzukommen diese
Charakterstärke die bezeichnet kann als
Tugend Laster hingegen nimmt er eine
Brot gesetzt widrige Gesinnungen und die
sind ungeheuer die er der Mensch zu
bekämpfen hat
weshalb dieses sittliche Stärke also die
Tugend als Tapferkeit wir haben gesehen
Aristoteles Kind auch die Tapferkeit als
Tugend den Mittelweg die Mitte zwischen
Tollkühnheit und Feigheit kann rekoriert
darauf auf die Tapferkeit die Größe und
einzig wahre kriegslehre des Menschen
ausmacht also wenn kann von Tapferkeit
spricht dann nicht von einer Tapferkeit
im Krieg gegen andere Menschen wie sich
eben alles tot ist noch gedacht hatte
sondern kann bezieht den Kampf ins
Innere des Subjekts deswegen ist es die
kriegst Ehre des individuellens Menschen
mit sich selbst der Kampf mit sich
selbst mit dem zum gegenüber dem
schlechteren ich sozusagen auch wird sie
die eigentlich nämlich praktische
Weißheit genannt diese Tapferkeit weil
sie den Endzweck des Daseins der
Menschen auf Erden zudem ihre Macht
ihren besitzt ist der Mensch allein frei
gesund reich ein König und so weiter und
kann wieder durch Zufall noch Schicksal
ein bösen weil er sich selbst besitzt
und der tugendhaft seine Tugend nicht
verlieren kann also der Mensch besitzt
sich selbst in der Tod warum weil er her
über seine
psychischen Verhältnisse ist und nicht
weil der tapfer ist im kriegste ist
tapfer gegenüber dem Kampf der sich
zwischen seiner Vernunft und den Lastern
bzw und den Neigungen die eben nicht dem
Sittengesetz folgen wollen abspielt
einer sehen wir ganz klaren Unterschied
also die Tugenden werden als innerliche
Verhältnisse
beschrieben und eigentlich als
Verhältnisse nach außen hin in der
Anwendung das ist sicherlich ganz
zentral wir haben ein weiteres Zitat
alle hochpreisungen er kann die das
Ideal der Menschheit in ihrem
moralischen Vollkommenheit betreffen
können durch die Beispiele des
widerspiegels dessen was die Menschen
jetzt sind gewesen sind oder vermutlich
künftig sein werden an ihrer praktischen
Realität nichts verlieren und die
Anthropologie welche auslosen
erfahrungskenntnissen also empirische
vorgehen kann der andere Punkt Nomi
welche von der und bedient
gesetzgebenden vernünftig aufgestellt
wird keinen Abbruch tun
anthroponometer steht der anthropus der
Mensch und des das Nomos der nomas das
ist das Gesetz also die
menschengesetzgebung das
menschheitsgesetz nicht die empirische
Wissenschaft von Menschen sondern die
Vernunft
Gesetzgebung des Menschen die ist ja mit
gemeint und irgendwie wohl tugende
Beziehung auf Menschen nicht aufs Gesetz
auch hin und wieder verdienstlich heißen
und einer Belohnung würdig sein kann so
muss ich doch für sich selbst so wie sie
ihr eigenes Weg ist auch als sie eigene
Lohn betrachtet werden also wir handeln
nicht tugendhaft nach kann damit wir
dadurch lohnen bekommen sondern die
Tugend ist selbst schon eigene Lohne
nämlich
opferkeit und innere Stabilität innere
Selbstherrschaft das ist so nach Kant
das Ziel das sagt weiter zu Tugend wird
zuerst erfordert die Herrschaft über
sich selbst Affekte und Leidenschaften
sagte sind voneinander unterschieden
also man muss sie jetzt immer schauen
der natürlich über Zufuhr gestellt dass
auch Affekte und Leidenschaften gegen
die Gebote des Sittengesetzes kämpfen
und das ist nach Kant eben die typische
Situation die ist bei David Hume zum
Beispiel nicht gibt nach jung können
Vernunft und Affekte nicht gegeneinander
kämpfen da kann so eine
Herrschaftsstruktur gar nicht auftreten
beziehungsweise die Vernunft sagt jung
ist dies klar wenn der Affekte sie soll
ihnen dienen und sie kann mit ihm gar
nicht kämpfen
muss zwei Formen von Tugend Ruhe
verstehen die hier ist negativ die
Tugend also sofern sie auf innere
Freiheit gegründet ist enthält für die
Menschen auch ein bejahendes geboten
nämlich alles seine Vermögen und Neigung
unter seine der Vernunft Gewalt zu
bringen mit hinterherrschaft über sich
selbst
das ist jetzt die Tugend weil ohne dass
die vernünftige ziegelte Regierung ihre
Handy nimmt jene über den Menschen den
Meister spielen also der Mensch soll
immer noch her seine eigenen psychischen
Verhältnisse sein die Seelenruhe die
attaxia darf nicht so zu verstehen sein
dass wir den Neigung den sinnlichen
begierten nachgehen sondern dass wir
innerlich eine Herrschaftsstruktur ich
habe Nieren können wo wir gar nicht mehr
am Ende einen Kampf uns befinden sind
die Neigungen und die perfekte die
Leidenschaften diese Maßen beschwichtigt
haben durch die
regierungszüge die wir
in die Hand nehmen
ja weiter sagte nun ist das Vermögen und
der überlegte Vorsatz an starken aber
ungerechten Gegner Widerstand zu tun die
Tapferkeit und den Anziehung des Gegners
der südlichen Gesinnung in uns trug und
Virus fortitudium Morales das ist ganz
interessant der Gegner von dem kann
spricht ist ja nicht wie bei aristotels
der Gegner im Krieg gegen den man sich
durch Tapferkeit auszahlen muss das ist
der Gegner uns ähm das Schlechte echte
Hand zum Bösen wie kann auch sagt die
Neigung und Triebe die uns dazu
verleiten
im Sittengesetz nicht Folge zu leisten
das ist nach Kant Tugend innere
Selbstverständnisse die eine
Herrschaftsstruktur der Vernunft
aufweisen jetzt unterscheidet er noch
Tugend von negative Untugend und Laster
und zwar ein logischer Hinsicht also
Tugend sei jetzt mal plus a also das
positiv ist ein positiver Wert dann ist
die negative Untugend also bloß die
untugen D als moralische Schwäche gleich
null
als logisches mir Gegenteil das Laster
unterscheidet er aber noch von der
Untugend die ist nicht nur die Untugend
also moralische Schwäche gleich null gar
nicht sondern sieht das gerade Gegenteil
das
kontare siberale
oppositum als das Gegenteil dass
deswegen auch nicht plus also minus a
ist das ist also ein aktives Widerspiel
gegen die Pflicht das kann man sich
fragen ob zu großen Verbrechen nicht
etwa mehr Stärke der Seele als selbst zu
großen Tugenden gehört da ist kann sehr
realistisch kann ein Verbrecher eine
Verbrecherin wir kennen zum Beispiel von
Schiller der Verbrecher aus verlorene
Ehre kann der vielleicht sogar eine
größere Seelen Stärke besitzen eine
Selbstherrschaft als ein moralischer
Mensch und diese Frage die diskutierte
üben kann auch ja vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit bis zum nächsten Sitzung
dann wieder im Präsenz